هنا صاروا وتجمعوا بين ازقه بيوتهم كانوا
عزلا فقط حاولوا حمايه عائلاتهم لكن
الاحتلال استهدفهم رغم علمه انهم مدنيون
عزل طائره اسرائيليه مسيره اطلقت صاروخا
فاستشهد عدد منهم على
الفور سمعنا صوت احنا الانفجار انفجار ضخم
صار وصارت الناس تصيح جينا لقينا الشباب
مقطعه يعني في الشارع هس اجت اسعاف اخذت
منهم والباقي الجيش ما خلى الاسعافات
وحملنا الباقيه يعني بعد مده
احمد احمد الله يتقبلك يا حبيبي ومن
تفاصيل سلوك جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الذين اقتحموا احدى سيارات الاسعاف انهم
طعنوا جريحا في رقبته فاستشهد واعتدوا
بالضرب على جرحى اخرين حوالي يمكن ست ل
سبع جنود فاتوا على امبلنس من ورا قعدونا
قدام احنا ممنوع تطلع لف شمال يمين فاتوا
على الشباب احنا ثلاث شباب معنا في
الاسعاف كانوا واحد مستشهد واثنين عايشين
في شب كان معنا سمتو سكينه في ركبته من
هون ونزلوا على جريهم كلفوا ش جريهم وتم
انتظارنا ساعه كامله ممنوع حدا يطب فيه
ممنوع حد يعمل شي فيهم اج التنسيق من
الهال الاحمر انه هذول الشباب معهم شهداء
ومدنيه فيش عليهم اي شي والشباب مش
مطاردين ولا ايشي عليهم
المره انه الاجتياح الرابع في ثلاثه ايام
اليات الاحتلال تصحب بجرافات ليتكرر
المشهد شهداء وجرحى وخراب ودمار الاطفال
ايضا كانوا هدفا بحرمانهم من الوصول الى
روضت التي دمرها جيش الاحتلال وفي ازقه
وشوارع مخيم نور شمس تجريف للبنى التحتيه
والكهرباء والماء والصرف الصحي وما تبقى
من شوارع مهما حاولوا مهما كسروا مهما
دمروا انا بحكي انه في صمود دائم داخل
المخيمات لا انكر الاذاء النفسي والاذاعي
والثاء المادي والتدمير والوجع وفقدان
الشهداء طبعا هذا صعب جدا والفقد صعب جدا
لكن هناك في استمراريه للمقاومه داخل
المخيم وصمود داخل الشعب الفلسطيني جيش
احتلال لم يعد يكتفي بالقتل بل يعدم جرح
في داخل سيارات الاسعاف ويهدد اخرين جيش
يعترف بان عدد الذين قتل من السابع من
اكتوبر تجاوز عدد الذين استشهدوا في
اجتياح الضفه الغربيه عام 2002 شهداء
وجرحى وخراب في 60 هجوما جويا واجتياح
بريه الجزيره طول
كرم